le harcèlement était un sujet et merci
de l'avoir rappelé que je prend
extrêmement au sérieux dans une petite
qui dort effectivement dans une certaine
continuité depuis dix ans qui a eu deux
premiers résultats mais qui va
maintenant aller plus loin je le prends
très au sérieux en tant que phénomène
humain qu'en tant que phénomène mondial
parce que le harcèlement et tendent
malheureusement un phénomène mondial
c'est le fait qu'il soit mondiale nous
amène à foix à voir qu'on a un sujet je
dirais anthropologique avec et
sociologique mais aussi de le voir avec
un relatif optimisme puisque on voit que
des pays arrivent à combattre le
harcèlement et je considère aussi que si
nous réussissons à combattre le
harcèlement scolaire et même parfois
l'éradiquer dans certains établissements
c'est que si c'est possible
quelque part c'est que c'est possible
partout et que d'autres pas le réussir
cela c'est réussir en fait l'ensemble
des enjeux de la vie scolaire puisque
cela signifie que lorsqu'on parle de
valeur la république on parle de
fraternité et que c'est ce qui doit
exister dans toute l'école dans tout
collège et dans tous les lycées et que
c'est faisable et que bien entendu ce
n'est pas la situation actuelle en tout
cas pas partout et que on a une grande
hétérogénéité et qu'on doit y arriver je
le pense je le dis en pensant aux
victimes du harcèlement je pense à
marjorie à al-hicha à marion pour
prendre les prénoms emblématique
d'enfants qui pour qui cela était
dramatique mais aussi à tous ceux pour
qui ça peut être moins dramatique mais
pourtant très grave dans les
conséquences que cela a eu sur leur vie
et sur la suite de leur scolarité
aucune forme de violence ne peut être
tolérée au sein d'écoles et d'une
certaine façon ce qui se joue là c'est
un petit peu dans la construction notre
société future donc comme vous le voyez
je ne prends pas du tout ce sujet au à
la légère je considère comme très
emblématique d'une finalement du contrat
social républicain tel qu'il se joue
dans l'enfance et dans l'adolescence et
le tout dans un contexte où nous venons
d'avoir le verdict dans la ferme il a
qui est évidemment pas sans rapport avec
ce nom nous parlons mais qui marque au
moins une étape importante dans le fait
que nous ne laissons pas le
cyberharcèlement impunis il faudra
évidemment faire de nouveaux progrès j'y
reviendrai en 2019 avec les pays membres
du g7 j'ai souhaité porter le sujet du
cyberharcèlement un niveau mondial parce
que le chacun comprend bien que cela
nous renvoie aux pratiques sur internet
et donc à des sujets de relations avec
les plateformes et que donc tous les
systèmes scolaires ont le même problème
est en fait ceci renvoie à ce que à de
nouvelles règles du jeu à chercher et à
trouver dans un cadre mondial donc j'ai
pris des initiatives comme vous le savez
là la première dame 1 macron s'est
impliqué sur ce sujet pour lui donner
tout le relief nécessaire et cet appel
avait été donc lancé avec elle lorsque
nous précisions le g7 cela signifie que
plusieurs pays sont entrés dans cette
logique avec nous et j'ai redoublé cet
appel le 5 novembre 2020 à l'unesco lors
de la conférence qui comme nous le
souhaitions s'est tenue sur le
harcèlement et qui par hasard un peu
tragique du calendrier s'est déroulé
quelques jours après l'assassinât de ça
mais elle pâtit qui lui aussi évidemment
fait écho à tout cela puisque c'était un
emballement sur les réseaux sociaux
comme chacun sait qu'ils étaient à
l'origine de cet assassinat donc
le sujet du cyberharcèlement mérite que
nous passions à une nouvelle étape et le
taux des travaux vous allez faire vont
certainement nous nous y aider je dois
dire d'emblée quelque chose que j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire ces derniers temps
c'est que nous avons deux premières
réussites importantes en matière de
lutte contre le harcèlement
nous le faisons reculer même si encore
beaucoup à faire et c'est les plus
premiers indicateurs que nous avons sont
encourageant en revanche nous n'avons
pas fait reculer le cyber harcèlement au
contraire il s'est développé de manière
très forte notamment à la faveur du
premier confinement et depuis lors de
sorte que les petites réussites du
premier côté sont malheureusement un peu
effacée par les échecs ou en tout cas
les insuffisances de l'autre donc nous
devons prendre toute la mesure du
phénomène et passer à une nouvelle étape
et je vais venir évidemment sur certains
points de cette nouvelle étape
vous le savez nous avons aussi renforcer
le cadre juridique
ces dernières années avec une
inscription dans la loi dans la loi pour
l'école de la confiance
c'était à l'article 5 aucun élève ne
doit subir de la part d'autres élèves
des faits de harcèlement ayant pour
objet ou pour effet une dégradation de
ses conditions d'apprentissage
susceptible de porter atteinte à ses
droits et à sa dignité ou d'altérer sa
santé physique ou mentale
c'est vraiment à mes yeux très important
d'avoir désormais cette base législative
qui est la référence pour l'action
publique désormais c'était d'ailleurs un
amendement d'erwan balanant qui nous
avait permis de l'inscrire et c'était
une très bonne chose
sa détermination à combattre ce fléau a
donc enclenché enclencher une
mobilisation générale avec un spectre de
mesures puisque je sais jamais une seule
mesure qui permet de ne répondre à de
tels problèmes d'abord en 2017
l'interdiction du téléphone portable
dans l'enceinte des collèges en plus des
écoles a été un progrès incontestable
parce que évidemment le téléphone
portable
ça fait partie des outils du harcèlement
et puis de différents problèmes
d'ailleurs au collège on n'en parle plus
tellement comme les choses qui
s'accomplissent positivement mais le
fait est que cette interdiction qui
était effective dans tous les collèges
de france est quelque chose de très bons
pour la vie concrète et quotidienne de
nos élèves en 2018 nous avons créé trois
cent trente cinq référents académique et
départementaux et créer des ambassadeurs
collégiens c'est une mesure là aussi
très importante parce que c'est à la
fois des adultes qui sont désormais en
responsabilité pour s'assurer de
l'effectivité des politiques de lutte
contre le harcèlement dans les
établissements mais aussi c'est la
responsabilisation des élèves eux mêmes
et on sait que c'est une clé majeure
autrement dit on a des vous savez des
ambassadeurs collégiens qui font un
travail remarquable quand 50 sur la
existent pour aller à la racine des
problèmes et changer la logique qui est
passé d'une logique de persécution du
faible entre guillemets à une logique ou
au contraire ont fait honte à tout celui
là tous ceux qui pratiquent le
harcèlement en 2019 nous avons lancé un
plan national qui était une sorte de
nouvelle de deuxième étape avec dix
mesures qui concernent la formation
systématique des professeurs et des
familles la création d'un comité
d'experts nationale qui d'ailleurs se
réunit demain jeudi 8 juillet pour pour
le bilan annuel
ce comité d'experts permet de travailler
sur les contenus pédagogiques et
scientifiques et s'assurer d'un suivi
aussi du sujet et nous avons aussi créé
le prix non aux harcèlements auxquels
ont participé cette année 48 l'élève 950
projet récompensant les productions
graphiques ou vidéo élaboré dans le
cadre d'un projet d'école ou
d'établissement ce prix à a désormais
beaucoup de 2,2 d'impact
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour signaler
que nous avions avant-hier les une
journée entière consacrée au sujet de
l'école inclusive et de ce que nous
faisons avec les élèves handicapés
il m'a été demandé par une association
hockey et j'ai tout à fait approuver
cette idée que cette année nous fassions
partie clairement attention au thème du
harcèlement des élèves handicapés
puisque on voit qu'un un pourcentage
plus grand que la moyenne qui sont
justement l'objet de harcèlements et
significatif aussi du fait que ce
concours est vu comme étant un outil
pertinent le
nous avons aussi développé le numéro
gratuit 30-20 auxquelles nous apportons
une subvention importante de 322 me
l'euro qui est le numéro d'écouté et de
prise en charge des familles des
victimes
avec en plus des lignes académie dédiée
avec des horaires étendus pour rejoindre
directement les référents académique et
départementaux et puis le numéro gratuit
30-18 que nous subventionnons aussi
auteur de 120000 euros pour signaler les
contenus indésirables sur les restes sur
les réseaux sociaux à la rentrée 2021
l'étape suivante doit être franchie
puisque c'est la généralisation à toutes
les académies du programme de prévention
de harcèlement que nous avons
expérimenté dans six académies pendant
deux ans ce programme phare que vous
avez regardé ce programme s'appuie vous
le savez sur le modèle des programmes
internationaux qui ont connu des
réussites on s'est beaucoup inspiré au
départ des modèles scandinaves auquel
vous avez fait allusion tout à l'heure
notamment le programme finlandais qui
ont justement font partie des pays qui
ont réussi à vraiment réduire très
fortement le harcèlement et donc les
grands halls les grands compte tenu de
cela vous le savez cette forme et
pendant huit jours cinq personnels par
établissement pour le repérage et le
traitement des cas et créer des parcours
pédagogiques pour les élèves avec 10
heures d'apprentissage annuel du cp à la
3e
pour moi on est au coeur de l'éducation
morale et civique et très concrète et
est donc ce n'est pas une brique de plus
dans la masse des choses que nous avons
à faire passer à nos élèves c'est
quelque chose qui vient renforcer
quelque chose qui de toute façon
doit elle fait nous avons aussi ajouté à
cela le permis internet collèges lycées
que nous avons étendu dans le projet de
loi comportant le respect des principes
de la république
à la fin du primaire c'est un amendement
des députés
caroline abadie et lætitia vient et puis
nous avons aussi
permis que les écoles les équipes
mobiles de sécurité les ems de
l'éducation nationale présente dans
toutes les académies pour la
sécurisation des écoles des collèges et
des lycées puis se suivent des
formations sur cet enjeu le renforcement
de la lutte contre les bandes fait aussi
partie de cela ainsi que le plan de
lutte contre les violences en milieu
scolaire avec la désignation d'un
référent départemental pour animer une
cellule violence cellules présentes dans
chaque direction académique est chargé
n'a suivi précis de tous les phénomènes
de violence en milieu scolaire
tout ceci vient s'insérer dans ce que
j'ai appelé le carré régalien qui est
aussi une innovation de cette année de
fin de la rentrée 2021 le car est
régalien à quatre côtés
c'est le sujet valeurs de la république
et laïcité c'est le sujet instruction en
famille et contrôle des écoles hors
contrat
c'est le sujet violence bande gang
drogue qui sont au coeur de nos plans
violence est en quatrième lieu le sujet
du harcèlement et du cyberharcèlement
chacun de ces quatre sujets est
différent des autres relève deux
logiques différentes mais l'objectif
c'est dans les quatre cas de s'assurer
d'un respect de la loi tout simplement
et des valeurs de la république et et
avec des équipes dédiées sur le modèle
de ce que nous avons déjà fait pour les
équipes valeurs de la république et
laïcité c'est à dire des équipes
capables d'intervenir sur le terrain on
soutient soit je dirais à froid pour des
actions de formation soit à chaud pour
aider les acteurs qui se sentent parfois
démunis face à des situations trop
complexe donc l'objectif du carré
régalien c'est qu'il n'y ait pas d'angle
mort c'est que dans toute l'académie
les quatre sujets soient vus et bien vu
avec les ressources humaines nécessaires
et les complémentarités de compétences
que tout cela appelle le j'étais
d'ailleurs hier à montpellier où g
j'ai fait une réunion au rectorat sur le
carré rigolade régalien de ce rectorat
et je fais attention actuellement trente
organisations des 30 recteurs sur cette
question pour que nous soyons bien prêt
à la rentrée conformément d'ailleurs à
certains engagements que j'avais pris
devant la représentation nationale
donc le système s'organisent de plus en
plus pour faire face à la question
notre stratégie est de diversifier les
angles d'attaqué d'avoir un spectre
large une vision à 360° pour la
mobilisation de tous les acteurs de
l'éducation nationale et des partenaires
de l'éducation nationale et puis la
prise de conscience et le travail des
élèves eux-mêmes pour qu'on va
durablement ce phénomène vous avez
demandé madame la présidente si on ne
devrait pas voter à l'idée de une sorte
de notation sur le sur ce qui est fait
en la matière dans chaque établissement
eh bien nous allons d'une certaine façon
dans ce sens avec maintenant le
déploiement de l'action du conseil
d'évaluation de l'école qui est une qui
était dans la loi pour l'école de la
confiance et qui est une réalité sur le
terrain depuis septembre dernier et vous
le savez l'idée d'évaluer tous les
établissements de france sur une période
de cinq ans par vagues de 2 20% chaque
année on a donc commencé cette année à
15 % puisque si on était un peu
contraint par la par l'épidémie mais
cette
cette évaluation j'en profite pour le
dire parce qu'on voit l'aspect
systémique de tout cela conduit d'avoir
une auto évaluation de l'établissement
puis à une établira une évaluation par
des équipes pluridisciplinaires
extérieur et parmi les grands domaines
d'auto évaluation et d'évaluation il ya
le climat scolaire et au coeur du climat
scolaire la politique de lutte contre le
harcèlement et donc il va y avoir une
prise de conscience et une
responsabilisation de plus en plus forte
autour de ce sujet avec des personnes
dédiée à cela partira mans sensible
sorte d'avant garde mais le globalement
une responsabilisation de tous
donc nous comptons beaucoup aussi sur ce
caractère un peu systémique et
systématique de la lutte contre le
harcèlement
cela devra s'accompagner je n'en doute
pas de mesures nouvelles encore dans les
temps à venir tout particulièrement sur
le sur le cyber harcèlement tant le
sujet aix est d'ailleurs le simple
domaine de l'éducation nationale et
mérite à la fois une vision globale à
l'échelle nationale et globale à
l'échelle internationale
mais en tout cas on ne doit pas se
laisser dominer par ces phénomènes de
société qui font beaucoup de tort et
être organisé tout simplement pour pour
y répondre et je crois que la direction
est prise évidemment il faut qu'on
franchisse encore deux nouveaux crans
merci monsieur le ministre je cède la
parole à notre rapporteur madame colette
mélot la présidente monsieur le ministre
je vous remercie pour ce premier tour
d'horizon de notre présentation nous a
proposé et qui constitue une très utile
contribution à notre réflexion
permettez moi de prolonger c'est ce
premier échange en vous faisant part de
plusieurs de mes interrogations nous
avons il ya quinze jours auditionné les
représentants des réseaux sociaux et de
nombreuses contradictions sont apparues
dans plusieurs de leurs principes
protection des personnes
versus secret des correspondances
libertés individuelles versus comme une
communication de données personnelles
aux réseaux sociaux pour faciliter la
reconnaissance d'éventuels harceleur
anonyme et cetera comment dès lors
opérer une conciliation entre objectifs
variés existe team différences
juridiques d' approche entre pays 0
européens car d'évidence la lutte contre
le cyber harcèlement ne peut se
concevoir dans un seul pays ont-ils
d'autres approches en ce qui concerne
les réseaux sociaux un grand nombre de
nos interlocuteurs notamment sur le
terrain ont attiré notre attention sur
le développement dramatique du sexting
et du revenge bornes
ainsi l'ensemble de la communauté
éducative et des partenaires de
l'éducation nationale rencontrée la
semaine dernière dans le pas de calais
souligné les dangers du cyber
harcèlement et la difficulté de lutter
conte
quel regard portez vous sur ce phénomène
comment agir pour supprimer
définitivement d'internet
des photos qui n'ont pas à y être
quelles relations entretenez-vous avec
les réseaux sociaux afin qu'ils sortent
clairement de l'ambiguïté actuelle et
cessent de se
réfugiée derrière le respect formel de
leurs obligations
bref qu'il soit enfin proactif et
participe à la sensibilisation et à la
formation des utilisateurs
ainsi comme l'a appelé monsieur eric
debarbieux la semaine dernière
l'obligation d'agir contre le
harcèlement dans les établissements
scolaires est déjà largement inscrite
dans le droit et vous venez de nous
rappeler qu'il avait été inscrit lors de
2 du projet de loi sur l'école de la
confiance
nous avons tous tous les textes qu'il
faut et comme nous l'a confirmé la
défenseur des droits
le problème qui se pose est celui de
leurs applications
comment par conséquent faire du travail
d'équipé entre les membres de la
communauté éducative une réalité pour
mieux lutter contre ces phénomènes
si la question des moyens ne saurait
tout expliquer ceux ci permettent
d'améliorer bien des situations
nous l'avons constaté lors de notre
déplacement dans un établissement ray
plus à meulan ou des temps sont dédiés à
ce travail des clips grâce à une
dotation supplémentaire qui permet de
former efficacement tous les personnels
ceci est dû à la laine la labellisation
cité éducative du territoire qui est une
aide importante pour l'établissement
enfin il sans empiéter sur le contenu
des programmes de scolaires
nous avons constaté une déficience en
matière d'éducation aux droits tant des
enfants que des parents au demeurant il
serait certainement important de leur
donner des notions
à ce niveau à ce niveau là n'est ce pas
l'occasion de les faire évoluer pour
mieux éduquer les enfants aux risques
bien réels du monde virtuel
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
d'avancé pour vos réponses se sont
beaucoup de questions et certainement
les collègues opposeront d'autres merci
mam l'a emporté alors c'est évidemment
des questions difficiles au making qui
n'appellent pas de réponse facile mais
là mais j'ai quand même
apporter quelques éléments d'abord
évidemment totalement d'accord avec tous
les constats que vous avez fait y
compris sur le développement par exemple
du sexy dance punk et là aussi quelque
chose qui est un phénomène mondial et la
difficulté qu'il ya à lutter contre tous
et ses pratiques sur sur internet alors
c'est vrai qu'il ya des principes qui
s'opposent qui se rentre en
contradiction c'est relativement
classique
combien de sur bien des sujets donc ça
doit pas nous nous effrayer plus que
sada voeu de voir liberté d'expression
en versus protection des personnes c'est
finalement un grand classique si j'ose
dire
antérieur à internet mais accentué par
par internet et on a
donc à trouver le bon équilibre puisque
victime en la liberté d'expression n'est
pas une petite chose est là mais la
question c'est évidemment la protection
des personnes pour moi je les idées
relativement clair sur cette question
c'était en matière de liberté
d'expression
tout est possible dans le domaine des
idées
et par contre la protection des
personnes justifie depuis fort longtemps
que l'insulté la diffamation ou pire
soit soit prohibée et donc c est cette
frontière là qu'on doit retrouver sur
internet
on a quand on regarde la question sur un
plan un peu européen on a d'un droit
pénal qui n'est pas harmonisée c'est
vrai en revanche le rgp des permet de
faire retirer des données personnelles
et donc ça c'est un élément commun aux
pays de l'union européenne de ce point
de vue là c'est vraiment un progrès il
ya aussi toute l'action de la cnil dont
qui est d'une certaine façon là la mise
en oeuvre de cette logique un gpd à
l'échelle de la france et donc on a même
cadre européen aujourd'hui pour les
réseaux sociaux pour lesquels on doit
pouvoir franchir de nouvelles étapes sur
le plan pratique de soi nul assez
intéressant ce sera intéressant pour moi
aussi de bien prendre connaissance de ce
que les représentants des plateformes
ont dit devant vous et non pas vu de ma
fenêtre tout exactement les mêmes
politiques et on pourrait essayer
d'avoir une harmonisation vers le haut
pour ceux qui ont le plus une action
positive ces dernières ces dernières
années mais il est évident qu'on doit
franchir un cran dans la responsable
responsabilisation que l'on doit leur
leur demander
elles ne sont pas de simples tuyaux
elles ont une responsabilité quant au
contenu et c'est en tout cas la
conception que je souhaite que je
souhaite pousser et je pense que les
éventuelles évolutions juridiques et
d'action administratif des temps à venir
doivent aller dans cette direction avec
une capacité d'injonction plus forte de
notre part
vis-à-vis des plateformes c'est en tout
cas sur le plan je dirais philosophique
et politique ce que je défendrai sur ce
qui ce sur les moyens d'action pour les
personnes concernées pour les personnes
touchées
le 30 18 et le 30 20 sont quand même de
bonnes réponses aujourd'hui qu'on peut
toujours améliorer mais qui en tout cas
déjà quand même bien fait leurs preuves
pour apporter des réponses les plus
rapides et les plus concrètes possible
la suite sur victime de harcèlement nous
y consacrons des moyens importants je
les ai je les ai mentionné tout à
l'heure et quant à votre autre question
sur les moyens c'est à dire comment
venir en appui aux établissements sur
pour pourrait aider à politique efficace
aux nues contre le harcèlement
ça va être le cas justement avec la
généralisation de du programme phare qui
suppose des sessions de formation et
donc nous mettons les moyens
correspondants à cela et dans l'exemple
que vous donnez de melun mais on le
retrouvera ce à de nombreuses reprises
avec l'extension donc du programme phare
dans toutes les dans tous les
établissements de france
[Musique]
merci monsieur nice nous allons prendre
les questions des deux premiers
collègues qui se sont inscrits donc
madame céline boulay ferronniers merci
beaucoup madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre on en a eu en a été un
plaisir à vous écouter et je me souviens
qu'au début de j'ai été élu sénateur je
vous avais posé la question sur le
harcèlement lors d'une audition et vous
m'aviez déjà donné l'impression de faire
beaucoup de choses alors pris la mesure
du phénomène et on avait évoqué qu'à
l'époque madame brigitte macro on avait
fait une cause nationale
je me souviens de ça mais à vous écouter
trois ans après j'ai quand même
l'impression c'est pas une critique
c'est un sentiment et vous me direz si
il peut être partagée ou non mais qui a
quand même un empilement de mesures que
vous êtes très actif mais a quand même
beaucoup
deux mesures qui sont prises je vais pas
toutes les citer on les a on les a
écoutés vous parlez de référents
académie pour parler de carhaix régalien
et de beaucoup de choses mais on a
l'impression que c'est un peu parfois
des cautères sur des jambes de bois ou
bien pour utiliser une autre expression
un peu familière le tonneau des danaïdes
surtout quand on parle d'augmentation de
harcèlement et notamment de
cyber-harcèlement parce que vous l'avez
dit vous-même dans votre propos
liminaire en fait si on arrive à juguler
un peu le harcèlement avec des résultats
le cyber harcèlement lui continue
d'augmenter de façon exponentielle
régulière et on se demande si et c'est
le sens de ma première question on se
demande parfois si finalement le
harcèlement entre guillemets classique
ne se transforme pas un peu
systématiquement en cyber harcèlement ce
qui est pour moi vraiment un véritable
point d'inquiétude après sur des
questions un peu un peu précises vous
avez parlé l'importance du climat de
classe là on est je pense tous d'accord
c'est la commission pour dire à quel
point c'est important et il en a été
question lors de notre audition d'un
député à midi mais vous avez a évoqué
aussi les ambassadeurs collégiens qui
sont à mon avis très important puisque
c'était la question des pairs comme un
enfant et me écouté par un autre enfant
que peut-être que par un adulte
mais je voulais vous poser la question
quid des délégués de classe qui était
très important à notre époque est ce
qu'il existe toujours parce que je me
souviens que quand on lise elysées le
délégué de classe qui pouvait servir
alors peut-être c'est des ambassadeurs
collégiens qui les ont remplacés mais
c'était là la première approche de la
citoyenneté et de l'engagement
il me semble qu'à un moment cette
élection a été mise à mal dans les
classes et je voulais savoir votre point
de vue là dessus je trouve trouve aussi
dommage qu'on n'ait pas et on a évoqué
également à midi dans d'évaluation
nationale sur le problème du harcèlement
et ce qui nous permettrait aussi de dire
comment ça évolue au fil des années et
d'évaluation aussi sur les numéros de
que vous avez évoqué les numéros
gratuits qui sont les 30 20 le 30 18 je
crois est ce qu on a un retour là dessus
est ce que ça marche auprès des jeunes
ou est ce que c'est un dispositif qui
mériterait d'être
être amélioré et dernière chose vous
avez parlé de liberté d'expression ça me
semble être un point qui est totalement
fondamentale la noce en liberté
d'expression est différente d'un pays à
l'autre
les réseaux sociaux sont américains très
souvent et la notion de liberté
d'expression aux états unis est très
différente de celle de la france est
très souvent j'ai déjà fait référence à
sa l'insultent est érigé en liberté
d'expression souvent la notion juridique
est mince et je pense que les enfants
peuvent ressentir les choses
différemment d'un adulte de ce point de
vue là et donc qu'est ce qu'il y a
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire juridiquement
par rapport à ça et notamment dans lé
interministériel je pense que il ya
plusieurs ministères qui devrait se
mettre autour de la table pour parler
pour parler de cela et ça me semble être
vraiment très important que les votes
retournait dessus merci monsieur le
ministre les questions étant nombreuses
je vais vous laisser répondre monsieur
le ministre peut être à cette série de
questions alors sur le sur la question
de l'empilement des mesures
c'est peut-être ma méthode d'exposer qui
n est pas la bonne mais à mes yeux ne
sont pas du tout empilés elles sont
articulés les unes avec les autres elles
forment un tout cohérent et l'essentiel
de ce que nous avons fait finalement le
renforcement de ce sujet qui qui existe
déjà mais que nous appuyons les exemples
de ça c'est pas simple car est régalien
qui est fait pour tout simplement donner
plus de force à la supervision
académique du sujet
il ne s'agit absolument pas d'une vision
qui serait verticale est stratosphérique
par rapport à des réalités de terrain
qui résisterait ça c'est l'image de du
pansement sur une jambe de bois me
paraît injuste puisque pas vis-à-vis de
moi parce que ça ça n'est pas grave mais
mais vis-à-vis tous ceux qui font cela
puisque l'objectif c'est justement
d'être sur le terrain en appui aux
établissements et donc en gros il ya les
petits et moyens problème quand vocation
à être réglé dans l'établissement par la
responsabilisation et la formation
et puis il ya les grands problèmes qui
nécessitent des interventions
extérieures donc et ensuite ces mesures
n'ont pas été vaine puisque le recul du
harcèlement et qui est une première
un premier élément je pense que c'est
d'ailleurs la première fois qu'on
constate un recul du harcèlement avec
donc des données dès que nous commençons
à voir des enquêtes
ce recul est une était quand même
encourageant
et puis ce qui est encore plus
encourageant c'est le fait que notre
expérimentation femme sur deux ans a
donné des résultats tout à fait probant
c'est ce qui nous permet d'aller vers la
généralisation
donc je crois que là il ya il ne faut
surtout pas tenir avec que nous ayons un
discours commander âge critique et pour
aller plus loin ça joue pas les mythes
le premier à le tenir en revanche je
pense qu'on doit éviter un discours
d'impuissance parce que il n'ya pas
d'impuissance et d'ailleurs c'est un
sujet qui qui transcende les clivages à
telle enseigne que je me suis sûr je
suis quasi sûr que vos conclusions je
les fais miennes
de l'issue de vos travaux parce que de
même que nous on la comparaison
internationale ce que nous recherchons
c'est avoir une somme d'idées
opérationnel que nous prendrons
cohérente et que nous renforcions en
tout cas comme vous l'avez compris comme
vous l'avez rappelé je vous en remercie
il n'y a pas de doute sur notre
motivation à faire à faire avancer les
choses sur
donc l'évaluation nationale sur le sur
le sur le phénomène
à l'appui de ce que je viens de dire
d'ailleurs donc nous avons demandé
désormais à l'adepte de faire des
enquêtes régulières sur sur cette
question les derniers chiffres donc
montré une première baisse ok tu es deux
ans en 2018 donc de 5 6%
c'est encore une fois une petite baisse
mais c'est tout de même une baisse alors
que tous nous indique que cela allait
que cela allait croissant précédemment
sur le sur le sujet de la liberté
d'expression dans le concept change d'un
pédalo c'est tout à fait juste de dire
cela d'où l'importance d'avoir au moins
une approche européenne et nous
l'importance des démarches dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure mais aussi d'avoir
des références unesco sur cette question
c'est pourquoi nous menons un travail
dans le cadre de l'unesco aussi sur sur
ce sujet là et même aussi dans le cas de
la francophonie d'ailleurs sur le sujet
des délégués de classe alors ça existe
toujours fort fort heureusement et
surtout ça a été renforcée par une
deuxième initiative c'est désormais vous
avez des éco délégués dans toutes les
classes des collèges et lycées de france
vient donc 250000 éco-délégués en plus
des délégués de classe
or les éco délégués ont comme standard
comme référence est ce qu'on appelle les
autres et des donc les objectifs de
développement durable qui sont assez
large qui inclut les sujets de de bonne
vie en commun et donc et d'ailleurs j'ai
il m'est arrivé en établissement de voir
des éco délégués qui était aussi
ambassador contre le harcèlement est
donc ces mesures là ce comme vous l'avez
dit d'ailleurs sont très importantes
parce que la chose la plus efficace est
évidemment de de responsabiliser les
élèves et donc on peut s'appuyer sur les
délégués
pour cela et ils vont être de plus en
plus mobilisés puisque le programme
phare passe par une formation aussi des
élèves
merci guillaume chevrollier oui merci à
mme la présidente monsieur le ministre
le cyber harcèlement et le harcèlement
témoigne aussi de la montée de la
violence dans notre société donc il faut
une réponse sécuritaire mais je vais
bien évidemment une réponse éducative et
avec des actions très concrètes et je
pense qu'il ya une voie qui mériterait
d'être empruntés et développer cesser
d'associer davantage les parents au sein
des établissements et travailler sur
cette alliance éducative entre parents
et enseignants sur ce sujet du
harcèlement et du cyber harcèlement mais
mais mais pas seulement sur celui ci
donc quelles propositions concrètes vous
pourriez faire pour associer davantage
les les parents dans l'école élan cadre
de cette mission d'information j'ai eu
l'occasion d'échanger bien évidemment
comme mes collègues avec des citoyens de
mon territoire et les retours terrain
des parents victimes dont les enfants
ont été victimes de harcèlement
tous témoignent dada manque d' écoute
des enseignants et de l'administration
d'une façon générale ou à chaque fois il
ya une certaine minimisation des faits
et peut-être aussi après donc ça fait
des parents qui sont démunis mais les
enseignants sont peut-être démunis face
aux situations donc quelle réponse vous
pouvez apporter
quelle réponse si vous pouvez apporter
aux situations dans les petites écoles
où tout le monde se connaît et donc là
les choses sont forcément différemment
des plus grands établissements
et enfin je rejoins ce qui a été dit sur
la nécessité d'avoir des données et à
caen aussi sur cette interrogation sur
une grande études de victimation pour
avoir un état des lieux et connaître les
chiffres petit peu comme dans d'autres
secteurs
les chiffres grille des faits aussi pour
avoir un état très très clairs et enfin
davantage de retours d'expériences de
l'initiative d'établissement parce que
comme vous l'avez dit c'est pas une
mesure qui permettra à régler les
problèmes mais c'est un ensemble de
moyens donc est ce que vous avez prévu
d'accentuer le travail de retour
d'expérience dans les établissements
notre pays merci je prends la question
de monsieur jacques grosperrin merci see
présidente
en plus c'est là en prolongement avec
celle de guillaume chevreau le choix
bourlier parce que je vous entendez
monsieur le ministre nous dire que c'est
un phénomène mondial et qu'il ya des
pays qui arrivent je sais pas s'ils
arrivent mieux qu'en france mais ça veut
dire qu'il ya peut-être des bonnes
pratiques qui existent et qui a un vrai
problème vis-à-vis du cyber harcèlement
j'entends tout l'engagement que que vous
avez vis-à-vis de ce problème de ce
drame pour les familles je sais que vous
avez fait une visioconférence avec tous
les collèges de france
dernièrement qui a été très bien perçue
par les chefs d'établissement et à
travers toutes les tout ce que vous êtes
en place que soient les ambassadeurs le
numéro 30 18 et ses terres est ce que
vous avez appelé tout à l'heure le carré
est régalien je pense que c'est quelque
chose dont vous n'êtes pas insensible et
votre politique le montre moi je
voudrais agir sur trois niveaux vous
pouvez questionné par rapport à trois
niveaux déjà par rapport aux
établissements les enseignants
on sait que dans chaque établissement il
ya ce qu'on appelle toujours l'effet
chef il ya des établissements on parle
tout à l'heure qu'il faut qu'ils aient
des classes où il ya une bonne ambiance
dans la classe mais c'est peut-être
aussi la bonne ambiance dans
l'établissement qu'il est important
est il vrai que dans certains
établissements parce qu'on sait très
bien que si un enfant qui harcèlent main
on l'exclût on peut être amené à exclure
l'ensemble des élèves outre
l'établissement est ce qu'il ya une
mesure qui est variable et j'ai cru
entendre chez certains chefs pour leur
dis bon il faut pas agir de la même
manière que si c'était un établissement
qui est plus tranquille en quelque sorte
parce que alors ça c'est un problème
parce que ça veut dire que le code de la
route en randonnée peut être divers en
fonction
ils ont aussi trouvé et les chefs
parfois cessantes un petit peu démunis
j'ai bien compris que plus on intervient
tôt plus le problème peut être résolu
simplement pour pouvoir intervenir tôt
il faut le savoir et c'est vrai que
c'est cesser d'y fixer difficile or donc
visent à lisser ses instructions aux
différences et pare-brise établissement
par rapport au climat de la classe par
rapport aux enseignants c'est aussi la
formation des enseignants
moi je me souviens dans la méthode
freinet lorsqu'un enfant voulait par
exemple se battre avec son petit
camarade vous le savez très bien il y
avait une petite boîte et puis écrivain
d'un petite boîte quelques choix en
disant voilà demain je vais mettre une
claque
mon camarade où je vais lui dire de
telles choses et ont validé le fait
d'écrire cela long mais il le faisait
pas donc c'était des métaux donc ça veut
dire qu'il ya peut-être aussi des
méthodes
alors je veux pas parler de ça mais
c'est vrai qu'elle peut-être aussi des
méthodes de formation chez les
enseignants qu'on pourrait apporter pour
pour les aider à régler cela en ce qui
concerne les enfants les parents dont on
a compris que les enfants avaient des
grosses difficultés à s'en ouvrir auprès
des personnes familières et c'est
souvent les parents qu'ils apprennent le
plus tardivement possible
comment libérer beaucoup plus et
davantage la parole que qu'ils le font
et lorsqu'on veut responsabiliser les
parents autant lorsque les parents les
enfants sont harcelés les parents bien
vite dans l'établissement et lorsqu on
explique aux parents que ce sont leurs
propres enfants qui harcèlent à ce
moment là ils n'entendent pas et il ya
des phénomènes de violence qui peuvent
être émis en direction des enseignants
et puis également dirigeant du chef
d'établissement donc comment peut-on
faire
ceci pour comment me donner on puisse
mieux responsabiliser les parents
si je crois que c'est aussi la
responsabilité des parents pour que man
de nice se sentent concernés et enfin
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya peut-être
quelque chose de juridica trouvez vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous avez
esquissé une piste par rapport à ça et
peut-être dans d'autres pays où on peut
agir de manière juridique peut-être puis
suffisante en tout cas supplémentaires
et enfin sur les partenaires on a
auditionné la semaine avec la présente
la rapporteure la défenseure des droits
qu'ils nous disaient qu'ils avaient des
délégués elle vous avez vraiment donné
interpellé sur la elle vous avez
sensibilisé sur sur le fait que
justement elle agir à ce niveau là et
puis qu'il souhaitait que l'éducation
nationale agissent également encore plus
particulièrement par rapport à ça c'est
ce qu'on pourrait pas imaginer que les
défenseurs des droits pour éventrer dans
un certain moment où dans un certain
système alors je sais qu'ils le font à
travers certaines choses mais qui soit
plus peut-être parties prenantes du
secteur
mais ça peut être mais simple et autres
personnes ou d'autres structures de
soutien de l'enfance en danger pour
faire en sorte qu'ils et toute une
communauté qui se trouve qu'ils se
rencontrent au sein de l'école au sein
des classes avec des moments peut-être
villégier alors avec moi j'ai tel
défenseur du drapeau l'effaceur de
moments solennels du lundi matin du quad
9 etc
mais je crois qu'il ya des moments où il
faut que cette parole sont libérés puis
les enfants sont véritablement qui sont
au sein d'écoles protéger là pour
apprendre et non pas pour se défendre
merci monsieur le ministre vous laisse
répondre à cette salve de questions
merci d'abord sur la question du
sénateur chevrolet sur le comment
associer les parents lors c'est
évidemment une question extrêmement
importante et et qui d'ailleurs
au delà du sud plus simple sujet du
harcèlement on sait que ça n'est pas
toujours un point fort de notre notre
école était d'ailleurs on peut aussi
voir la problématique sous différents
angles qui est d'ailleurs celle que un
moment donné a eu le sénateur européen
c'est à dire le fait qu'on voit aussi
beaucoup de 2
de non-respect des professeurs par les
parents et une contestation forte de
temps en temps de décision vis-à-vis
d'enfants a reçus hier par exemple et
saison que tout un
tout un mode de relation entre les
écoles et les parents l'école et les
parents que l'on doit inventer mais qui
ne va pas dans un seul sens comme vous
le savez dans la loi pour l'école de la
confiance on a d'ailleurs inscrit dans
le marbre le fait que le respect des
professeurs n'étaient dues et que et que
contesté de manière virulente ou
violentes des décisions professoral est
constitutif de quelque chose qui doit
être sanctionné mais au delà ce principe
là il ya la nécessité de créer des
relations fluide entre parents
parents et écoles tout ça peut aller de
pair avec le fait que parfois la
établissement comprend mal qu'il ya des
situations de harcèlement et on a donc
tous les cas de figure sur sur le
terrain les dispositifs qui permettent
d'avancer sur ces sujets c'est notamment
la mallette des parents qui est un
dispositif qui maintenant a vraiment
fait ses preuves et qui permet en début
d'année d'avoir des petits groupes avec
les parents pour bien les les leur faire
prendre conscience à la fois des règles
du jeu de l'école et aussi du fait
qu'ils sont bienvenus à l'école et une
capacité aussi à traiter les problèmes
le plus possible à la racine
et c'est vrai que comme vous l'avez dit
dans les petites écoles tout le monde se
connaît ça peut être un atout mais
parfois c'est un c'est un problème quand
les choses se sont dégradées à un
certain stade la consigne j'en parlais
encore y alliant dans cette réunion dont
je laquelle j'ai fait référence et de
d'être capable de bien montrer que la
force doit être du côté du droit et pas
du côté de ceux qui harcèlent ou des
familles qui montre un peu les muscles
dans certaines circonstances qui est
malheureusement ce qu'on voit dans
certaines dans certains endroits sur les
données
les deux sur les données comme à la
suite de questions qui ont été posées
aussi par précédemment donc je voudrais
dire que notre le comité qui se réunit
demain est fait aussi pour à la fois
analysé les données que nous produisons
par nos enquêtes mais aussi
éventuellement suggérer d'autres
d'autres approches mais avec le conseil
d'évaluation de l'école en particulier
et nous allons commencer à voir
maintenant de la donne est de plus en
plus consolidée sur le sur le phénomène
mais encore une fois ce que nous faisons
au travers de l'adf nous a déjà permis
de voir une baisse de harcèlement comme
je le disais tout à l'heure
aussi bien à l'école primaire et au
collège
au lycée le développement du
cyberharcèlement se recevoir plus que
dans les niveaux inférieurs sur
ce qu'a dit le sénateur grosperrin sur
l'exclusion des des élèves
donc là aussi pratique plus large que le
harcèlement c'est à dire au fond comment
nous ont respecté les règles
dans les établissements nous avons pris
des mesures vous savez dans le cadre du
plan violences notamment pour aller à la
systématicité des signalements donc je
le redis la doctrine de l'éducation
nationale n'est pas le pas de vagues ou
le non signalement ou les problèmes sous
le tapis quel que soit l'expression
qu'on utilise je sais que c'est quelque
chose que l'on continue à dire mais ça
doit être très clair et donc je profite
de chaque occasion comme celle-ci pour
le dire c'est ce n'est pas ce que j'ai
demandé depuis 2010 est j'ai été très
clair sur le fait par exemple qu'un
établissement n'est pas évalué sur le
nombre de signalements le fait d'avoir
de nombreux signalements n'est pas
quelque chose qui se retourne ensuite
contre le chef d'établissement
je ne dis pas qu'il ya pas eu d logique
de ce genre auparavant jeudi que depuis
2010 est le message institutionnel est
très clair et donc c'est un peu comme
sur le sujet précédent je crois qu'on
doit être attentif à ne pas faire comme
si le pas de vagues étaient la doctrine
de l'éducation nationale c'est à dire
pas du tout ce que vous avez dit parce
que on entretient le phénomène parce qu
il est exact que certains acteurs ont pu
intégrer la logique du paddock et qui
peut y avoir des traces et sédimentation
si je puis dire
un peu comme quand vous achetez une
tablette de chocolat et qu'on vous dit
qu'il ya des traces de cacahuètes là il
peut y avoir des traces du pas de vagues
dans la prenant les politiques publiques
menés mais mais certainement pas du fait
de la volonté de l'institution et donc
le message est très clair
au contraire il faut
signalez est donc dans le plan violence
on a demandé signe signalement
systématique et réactions automatiques
et proportionnée l'exclusion l'élève
dans le donc avoir lieu d'une manière je
dirais qu'il correspond à un standard
national bien sûr que l'exclusion n'est
jamais
une chose est éminemment souhaitable en
soi parce que c'est c'est pas la mesure
la plus les plus éducative
mais parfois les justifier et lorsque
les élèves deviennent des poly exclus
comme cela comme cela arrive nous avons
pris une série de mesures pour pouvoir
traiter ce phénomène notamment dans des
temps des structures dédiées donc le
évidemment que cette politique de lutte
contre les violences à un impact aussi
sur la politique de lutte contre le
harcèlement et est donc je pense qu'on
arrive à quelque chose de plus homogène
maintenant il tout à fait exact de se
dire mais j'ai eu comme vous l'avait dit
et comme je l'avais dit tout à l'heure
que plus on intervient tôt plus le
problème est résolu et que tout ceci
nous renvoie aussi à des sujets
pédagogique de nombreuses initiatives
sont prises c'est vrai que comme souvent
avec les sujets de l'éducation quand on
tient à un fil on tire toute la pelote
de deux des sujets l'éducation nationale
donc il est vrai que par exemple si on
réussit réussi à ce que tous les élèves
savent bien lire écrire compter et
respecter autrui
j'avais d'ailleurs j'en profite pour
dire que respecter autrui c'est à une
sorte de quatrième pilier que vous
souhaitez ajouter dès le début dans les
savoirs fondamentaux et qui bien sûr
englobe le sujet de la lutte contre le
harcèlement
et bien si on réussit ça on sait très
bien que des élèves consolidé sur le
plan de leurs savoirs sont moins
violents - harceleur que lorsqu'il ya
une sorte de malaise
vis-à-vis de l'institution scolaire dans
de la part d'un élève et donc les enjeux
de vocabulaire fonds en font partie mais
aussi toutes les initiatives que nous
prenons au titre des compétences
sociales des élèves
et il peut y avoir des initiatives
pédagogiques comme celles que vous avez
cités en faisant référence à a freiné et
c'est vrai que tout ce que nous allons
faire aussi au titre de l'engagement des
élèves fait partie de cette stratégie
éducative
je voudrais m'arrêter un instant sur
cela parce que ça fait écho encore une
fois la dimension systémique du sujet
j'ai toujours dit que dans les sociétés
sécularisées comme la nôtre
on sent parfois un manque qui est celui
du moment initiatique pour les dans les
sociétés anciennes il ya ce sous la
forme religieuse sur les formes diverses
et variées anciennes l'adolescent qui
rentre dans l'adolescence fait l'objet
d'un rite de quelque chose qui fait
rentrer dans dans ce nouvel âge et
et aujourd'hui finalement c'est l'entrée
au collège qui joue ce rôle mais qui le
fait un parfaitement et quand il n'ya
pas de ritualisation de cette entrée
dans l'adolescence elle se fait par des
voies diverses comme les bandes par
exemple
et où déboucher sur des phénomènes comme
la drogue le fondamentalisme ou d'autre
chose on doit donc beaucoup plus
ritualisé l'arrivée au collège est
beaucoup plus favoriser les phénomènes
d'engagement positif des élèves
c'est le sens par exemple des éco
délégués dont dont j'ai parlé mais aussi
des initiatives que nous prenons pour
favoriser l'engagement dés l'âge du
collège par exemple avec le secourisme
avec les partenariats avec la
gendarmerie les pompiers etc et le snj
est aussi un signal que nous envoyons
non seulement aux élèves de 16 ans
concernés mais même en amont de cet âge
en matière d'engagement donc des élèves
engagée dans des causes d'intérêt
général sont des élèves qui ont très peu
de chances d'être venir parce leur et
qui en tout cas ce qu'ont développé un
système de valeurs qui est la meilleure
des vaccins contre ces problèmes
donc oui le sujet pédagogique et
éducatif en premier lieu comme toujours
dans nos domaines et on doit
on doit donc là encore avoir la vision
systémique de ce sujet je veux pas être
trop long parce que en effet on peut
dire beaucoup de choses à partir de là
mais en tout cas sur la parole des
parents dont vous avez parlé aussi les
vous avez dit à juste titre que les
parents n'entendent pas que leur ont du
mal parfois en tant que leurs enfants et
harceleurs c'est vrai que quand on parle
de ses juges on parle toujours du ratio
l'aimé on parle du du du harceleur et il
est fréquent d'ailleurs que quand on
fait des dés quand on interroge des
élèves parfois ils sont pas conscients
d'être harceleur et c'est un travail sur
le sujet qui fait héberger le fait que à
certains moments
un enfant peut être cela parfois il
arrive qu'un enfant soit et harceleurs
et harcelés et donc nous devons
travailler sur cette parole des parents
dans le sens que je commençais a indiqué
tout à l'heure ça pourrait passer
peut-être par une généralisation de la
mallette des parents est en tout cas une
orientation de la mallette des parents
vers le sujet harcèlement enfin sur ce
que vous avez dit sur la défenseur des
droits enfin l'éducation nationale je
suis d'accord avec l'esprit de votre
question à l'éducation nationale fait la
correspondante de la défenseure des mois
en face qui ce qui correspond à cette
fonction c'est la médiatrice de
l'éducation nationale et qui est 4e
bisiaux actuellement et vous comme vous
avez un médiateur dans chaque académie
de sorte que compte l'institution
n'a pas résolu un problème et qu'il
demeure la médiatrice où les médiateurs
sont de plus en plus saisi et joue un
rôle essentiel et il son correspondant
de manière tout à fait juridiquement
établi de la défenseure des je pense
qu'il faudrait pas superposer un nouveau
dispositif met vraiment
pleinement ce que je crois nous faisons
beaucoup mais on peut le faire plus
pleinement prendre en compte le rôle des
médiateurs dans cette danse est dans son
rôle et d'ailleurs en parlant de
médiateur et puisque nous avons parlé
des délégués et des ambassadeurs contre
le harcèlement
c'est l'information à la médiation qui
sont proposées aussi aux élèves pour
qu'ils savent pour qui se prennent dès
le plus jeune âge à être médiateur dans
les conflits et et apprendre 7,7 des
façons de faire qui installe de la paix
et de la fraternité dans la relation des
élèves au quotidien
merci monsieur le ministre thomas
d'haussy merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre la question des
données est revenu plusieurs fois mais
parce que je pense que c'est important
on avait déjà eu cet échange sur les
données concernant les atteintes à la
laïcité qui était compliqué à obtenir
vous l'aviez reconnu et là nous vous
nous parler d' enquête assez large et
aussi des signalements est ce que à
terme il est prévu peut-être de rendre
publique
le nombre de signalements alors pas
forcément par l'établissement parce que
comme vous l'avez dit faux pas évaluer
les établissements en fonction de de ces
données là mais peut-être par académie
pour savoir à peu près où on se situe et
peut-être évaluer justement les
établissements qui font ce qu'ils
mettent en place certains dispositifs
savoir ce qui fonctionne qui fonctionne
pas ça permettrait aussi face voilà avec
le spectre ne mesure que vous nous avez
annoncé ça permet aussi d'évaluer un peu
plus clairement ce qui fonctionne ce qui
n'a pas forcément d'impact important
nous ça si vous aviez prévu de les
rendre publiques ces données et puis
l'autre question que tu que j'avais
c'était sur l'accompagnement des
victimes de harcèlement est ce que au
sein de la médecine scolaire et les
déformations qui sont prévues à la
médecine scolaire et c'est un chantier
assez important aussi parce qu'elle a un
peu en souffrance
actuellement mais est-ce qu'il ya eu les
possibilités d'avoir des informations
sur ce qui est actuellement en place
pour que les peut-être à au sein de la
médecine scolaire y aider de
l'accompagnement des victimes de
harcèlement et puis je pense que si on
veut limiter le sentiment d'impunité des
harceleurs mais c'est dans le ce que
vous nous avez décrit a déjà des
dispositifs qui sont faites il faut
limiter les délais entre les
signalements et l'action qui est mise en
place et
j'ai l'impression que c'est quand même
pas très clair quand on est quand on
doit orienter une victime de harcèlement
sur sur la façon dont elle peut se
défendre
entre les deux numéros de téléphone
entre l'équipe pédagogique à qui elle
peut signaler des choses et puis
peut-être aller en justice donc il ya
quelque chose qui me paraît un peu
touffu là dedans et est ce que il est
prévu peut-être de simplifier sa faut
avoir on va dire pour limiter le temps
entre le signalement d'un phénomène de
harcèlement et l'action qui mise en
place par l'institution et enfin sur les
réseaux sociaux ou parler d'interdiction
du téléphone mois au delà de
l'interdiction parce que en gros il ya
un besoin de formation les élèves sont
autodidactes sûr c'est sur ces plates
formes là est peut-être passe à côté de
de ce qui est possible de faire une fois
qu'on est victime de harcèlement à
travers son téléphone qui nous quitte
qui ne les quitte plus y compris au sein
du domicile familial peut être il ya
besoin d'une formation un peu plus large
aux réseaux sociaux et sur ses plates
formes à ossun ii
des écoles et des collèges et des lycées
est-ce que là dessus il ya quelque chose
qui peut être accentué voilà mes
questions je me permets d'ajouter une
question dans le prolongement de ce que
vous venez de dire n'était pas possible
de faire connaître à tous les collégiens
les applique comme bodyguard qui
existent et qui fonctionne bien comme
comment on prévient sur les pare feux
les antivirus quand on se sert d'un
ordinateur
[Musique]
je voulais je réponds maintenant il ya
encore une question de monsieur bourgi
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
merci beaucoup pour les propos que vous
avez tenus hier à montpellier
département dont je suis l'élu d'enjeux
ferez connaissance avec beaucoup
d'intérêt dans le journal local le midi
libre et merci beaucoup pour les propos
que vous venez de développer ici j'aurai
deux questions la première c'est
concernant ce carré régalien que vous
voulez mettre en place à la rentrée
prochaine
est ce que vous avez prévu des
personnels dédiés pour veiller au
respect de ce carré régalien ou est ce
que c'est un moyen constant en
redéployant des effectifs qui existe
déjà
sachant que aujourd'hui au niveau du
rectorat et des inspections d'académie
on se rend compte qu'il travaille à flux
tendu si jamais vous leur a signé de
nouvelles missions et que vous ne leur
donnez pas les moyens humains afin de
remplir ces missions service offre un
petit peu compliqué et décevant tant
pour vous que pour nous la deuxième
interrogation que je voudrais formuler
c'est suite à l'audition que nous avons
faite auprès des représentants des
réseaux sociaux facebook snapshot tik
tok et quelques autres chez lesquels
j'ai senti plutôt un sentiment de
minoration de défausse lorsqu'on leur
parle et de la gravité de la situation
de son ampleur il se défausser et ils
minorée et dans leurs stratégies de
réponse et même de défense il utilisait
le fait que vous aviez participé à des
après midi de chat qui réunissait cinq
cents jeunes
je n'ai absolument rien contre les
séances de chat qui réunissent quelques
centaines de personnes
mais lorsqu'on a des centaines de
milliers de jeunes dans notre pays qui
sont confrontés à ce risque là qu'est ce
que c'est c'est 500 ou 600 jeunes qui
participent à une après-midi de chat
avec le ministre donc je ne voudrais pas
que les réseaux sociaux utilisent votre
participation pour nous montrer ou pour
essayer de nous prouver qu'ils font le
maximum de choses et qu'ils ont
finalement la bénédiction du ministre et
du ministère pour ne pas
au delà de ce qu'ils font parce que j'ai
le sentiment qu'ils font le service
minimum et je ne voudrais pas qu'à votre
insu et puis utilisez votre
participation à ce genre de
manifestation pour le passeur davantage
toujours là six ministres merci beaucoup
alors d'abord sur la première série
question que sur la transparence des
données
je pense que nous allons aller donc vers
plus de données
bakaba de non-transparence actuellement
les données que nous avons nous les
donnons simplement on peut considérer
que dans le passé finalement le
phénomène a été pas assez bien mesuré
donc la question me semble-t-il est
celle de la finesse de notre information
d'où ce que j'ai dit précédemment sur
désormais la systématicité des enquêtes
ça peut être à l'échelle des
établissements non pas pour les
signalements en effet comme vous l'avez
dit mais mais pour le clae le climat
scolaire donc vraiment donné quitus un
établissement d'une bonne politique de
climat scolaire et donc de lutte contre
le harcèlement
et puis effectivement à l'échelle d'une
académie être capable comme vous l'avez
dit de faire le point sur l'évolution de
la de la situation nous nous nous en
sommes capables désormais d'ailleurs le
cas régalien sur lequel je vais revenir
va contribuer à ça c'est à dire
meilleure collecte des données et un
meilleur portrait de ce qui se passe en
matière de violence mais aussi en
matière de harcèlement
je rappelle que sur le sujet des
violences ont fait des progrès très
importants comme d'ailleurs sur le sujet
laïcité sur lequel nous sommes capables
désormais de donner des données
transparentes
chaque trimestre sur l'accompagnement
des des victimes
vous avez fait référence à juste titre à
la médecine scolaire j'ai sur lequel on
prendra aussi des initiatives parce que
c'est exact de dire que qu'elle est
parfois sous calibré par rapport à tous
les enjeux a fortiori dans la crise que
nous venons de traverser
et on sait que par exemple les
infirmières scolaires comme les médecins
jouent un rôle important mais au
quotidien pour recevoir les élèves et et
être à l'écouté et en tirer parfois des
conséquences comme d'autres personnels
d'ailleurs que sont les psychologues ou
les assistantes sociales
et puis les professeurs eux-mêmes qui
souvent sont dans dans ce rôle sur
la question de l'impunité
vous avez raison ce 2 je pense de dire
qu'il faut qu'on limite le temps entre
le signalement et la réaction de
l'institution de nouveau le carré
régalien est là pour cela c'est à dire
avoir chaque soir sur le bureau
directeur
les signalements de la journée chaque
semaine les réunions approprié et des
réactions immédiates de l'institution
pour venir en appui de l'établissement
ou autre coup à tout le moins interrogés
l'établissement sur ce qui se passe et
et les réponses qui sont qui sont
importés donc ça c'est vraiment on
retrouve la question de précédentes sur
la transmission les sur la question des
données
c'est à dire puisque ces deux questions
d'enfants qu'une c'est d'ailleurs la
remontée des éléments et non pas pour
faire juste des statistiques bien sûr
mais mais pour être capable de réagir
immédiatement sur les formations pour
maîtriser internet
c'est évidemment là aussi un sujet très
important auquel mais aussi avancé
rappelons que ça fait évidemment partie
du programme du programme phare qui
d'ailleurs comporte par rapport aux
questions qui ont été posées de fer sur
la famille un volet famille dans chaque
établissement
appliquant phare il ya des ateliers
dénommé famille pour pour cela sept
et donc désormais aussi bien dans la
formation des futurs professeurs que
dans la formation continue des
professeurs et des personnels que dans
la formation des élèves même la lutte
contre le harcèlement est inscrite et
fait partie de la stratégie suivie sur
les questions qui ont été posées au
sujet du carré régalien louis d'abord
merci pour vos propos initiaux mais sur
les sénateurs sur la sur les
alors oui il ya des personnels dédiés
sur les quatre points et c'est un des
objectifs sur certains de ces points
j'ai eu à m'engager devant devant vous
sénateurs et sénatrices et aussi devant
les députés sur notre cas par exemple
sur les sujets d'instruction en famille
j'ai eu à m'engager sur fait d'étoffer
les équipes parce que on a souvent dit
qu'on soit pour ou contre la loi que ce
qui manquait c'était une tout simplement
les ressources humaines pour effectuer
les contrôles nécessaires donc c'est un
exemple typique d où on et off les
équipes
et la réunion que j'ai eue hier à
montpellier était assez significative
d'autres réunions qu'on peut avoir dans
d'autres parties de france c'est à dire
on a réellement aujourd'hui des équipes
donc des sujets qui étaient épars
auparavant qui parfois même était peu ou
mal traités sont désormais des sujets
encore une fois qu'ils sont
d'où cette notion de carrière et galien
c'est à dire que ces déchets qui sont
rassemblés articulé entre eux et font
l'objet sur chacun des quatre points
d'une capacité d'intervention de
l'institution et d'une vision rh du
sujet c'est à dire que lorsqu'on se rend
compte que il ya des faiblesses dans un
endroit bien on regarde qui s'en
occupent ce ne sont ils pas assez
nombreux ne sont ils pas assez formés et
donc 7
cette approche permet un peu de
rassembler les les analyses que l'on
peut faire est d'être plus efficace sur
ce que vous avez dit sur les réseaux
sociaux
d'abord je vais faire attention
effectivement ne pas servir de caution
d'une quelconque manière
c'est important que nous et nous sachons
bien utiliser les réseaux sociaux nous
en tant que institution
et pour relayer des messages positifs
vis-à-vis des élèves que ce que nous
faisons parfois nous il faut qu
évidemment on n'en réussit sa affaires à
faire valoir des logiques positif donc
au travers des réseaux sociaux
maintenant vous avez dit qu' il y avait
une forme de défaut c'est la part des
responsables des réseaux sociaux sur la
question du cyber harcèlement
je crains que vous n'ayez raison il sait
vraiment
est-ce que j'ai commencé à dire tout à
l'heure et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
dans la suite de vos travaux mais aussi
de la réunion que de demain j'ai bien
l'intention dans de nouvelles
initiatives en la matière de façon à ce
que encore une fois les responsables de
réseaux sociaux ne se considèrent pas
comme des responsables de tuyaux sur
certains sujets d'ailleurs il se
considère pas comme responsable de
tuyaux et que donc on aille au bout de
la responsabilisation de chacun
dans l'eure notamment dans leur
réactivité et aussi dans leur capacité à
à consacrer des moyens et du temps de
l'énergie et des contenus à la lutte
contre le contre le harcèlement
et si on est capable de censure et
donald trump on doit être capable de
censurer le harceleur du coin je reviens
sur ma question pratico pratique de tout
à l'heure et est ce difficile de donner
aux élèves les outils qui existent qui
permettent de les protéger des qui dès
qu'ils s'en servent en fait j'ai une
autre question j'en profite ne
faudrait-il pas prévoir un délit
spécifique de harcèlement scolaire
ne serait ce que pour afficher
clairement à un interdit sociétal alors
sur le sur la deuxième question sur le
délit dans clients nous avons inscrit
dans la loi pour les codes de la
confiance cela le fait qu' il y avait un
droit à ne pas être harcelé dont la
conséquence il était évidemment que
quelqu'un qui harcèlent doit être
poursuivi il ya un arsenal juridique
d'ailleurs le procès milla sur la
cession du cyberharcèlement montre bien
qu'il ya des outils juridiques désormais
pour lutter contre l' attaque on me tend
quelque sorte donc peut-être y at-il de
nouvelles
mesures à prendre sur le plan juridique
je n'en suis pas certain je pense qu'on
allait les outils pour cela mais s'il
fallait le faire j'y serai je serai
évidemment partisans sur le lac estion
donc des outils que l'on pourrait
diffuser
là aussi je vais pas vous répondre de
but en blanc sans analyser ce qu'il en
est mais évidemment que si cela est
et si les droits son livre aussi si
techniquement c'est faisable je ne vois
que des avantages à être capable de
faire cela et si vous voulez le
programme phare peut être vraiment le
véhicule de ces choses c'était avec
l'avantagé programme phare c'est qu'il
évidemment évolutif que nous continuons
à regarder les bonnes pratiques
mondiales et c'est d'ailleurs ce que la
réunion de demain permettra de faire et
que donc on peut il ya 200 arrêts le
faire évoluer en terme de contenu et et
y compris au travers des outils
numériques que l'on peut
incluant bien merci at-il encore
d'autres questions de l'ademe le
rapporteur je vais rajouter une autre
question pratico pratique est ce que le
programme phare peu en début d'année
scolaire présenté l amour à l'ensemble
de la communauté scolaire
les différentes mesures et sensibiliser
à la fois les personnels et les familles
ainsi que les élèves d'ailleurs je
parlais tout à l'heure
d une déficience en matière d'éducation
aux droits
est ce que tout cela pourrait peut-être
expliquer parce que bon on va dire on
met le programme phare en place aux
familles aux enseignants si ça ne va pas
plus loin c'est pas suffisante il
faudrait vraiment qu'une chaque année on
réunissent les parents même qu'on leur
fasse signer un contrat enfin qu'il y
ait vraiment un du pragmatisme aussi en
la matière oui je crois que la
généralisation du programme par va dans
le sens de ce que vous dites pas ce
qu'il ya
nécessairement en début d'année de
l'exposé de la stratégie de
l'établissement et notamment dans l'air
dans les réunions par an avec les
parents de début d'année
et en plus il ya une adaptabilité du
programme établissement par
établissement ce qui fait que des idées
comme la signature du règlement de
l'établissement et la signature de la
stratégie de lutte contre le harcèlement
sont des choses tout à fait faisable à
l'échelle de chaque établissement
le vraiment je pense que j'aurai
beaucoup insisté sur ça aujourd'hui mais
la généralisation de phare à la rentrée
prochaine est un événement extrêmement
important
on a encore une fois un véhicule mais un
outil de prise de conscience très fort
et donc le début d'année sera beaucoup
placé sous ce cet hospice
[Musique]